so in this table here we have two
different communities community one and
community two and each of them contained
three different species and we see the
populations of those three different
species and we also see that the total
number of individuals in each community
is the same they both have a total of 1
000 individuals now my question to you
just intuitively based on the data in
this table which community would you say
is more diverse and why community 1 or
community two
all right now let's think about this
together so as we already talked about
they have the same number of individuals
and you might be thinking that the
number of species could be related to
the diversity and you'd be right the
number of species does contribute to the
diversity but we're dealing with a
situation where both communities have
the same number of species they each
have three species
but when we look at the data it's clear
that community two is mostly species a
and you have very small groups of
species b and species c
while community 1 is more evenly spread
so just intuitively it feels like
community 1 is maybe
more
diverse
but this was just on my intuition or our
intuition and the numbers are pretty
clear here it's evenly distributed
amongst the species here and here it's
very heavily weighted on species a
but it might not always be this clear so
it'd be useful to have some type of
quantitative way to measure the
diversity of a population and lucky for
us there is a quantitative quantitative
way to do that called simpsons
i'll write it down
simpson's diversity
index
and the way you calculate it it's equal
to 1 minus the sum
of
for each species you take the number in
that of that species divided by the
community size
squared so for each of the species you
do this calculation square it and then
you add it up for each of those species
so let's figure out simpson's diversity
index for both communities one and
community two and i encourage you you
could pause the video and try to work on
it on your own before i work through it
with you
so let's start with community one
so i'll say diversity
index for community one i'll just put
that in parentheses is going to be equal
to one
minus so we have 325
over over one thousand
squared
remember we're going to sum on each of
these species plus
305
305
over 1000
squared
plus
370.
over
1000
squared and i need to close my
parentheses
and i can simplify this a little bit
this is going to be equal to 1 minus
so all of these thousand squares a
thousand squared is a million so it's
going to be everything over 1 million
1 million and then we're going to have
325
squared plus 305 squared plus 370
squared
and that is going to give us 325
squared
plus
305
squared
plus 370
squared is equal to that that's the
numerator here and i'm going to divide
that by a million divided by
1 1 2 3 1 2 3.
that is a million it equals this and
then i'm going to subtract that from 1.
so i'll just put a negative sign here
and say plus 1
is equal to
0.664
so this is going to be approximately
equal to 0.664
now let's do the same thing for
community
2. so if i write it over here the
diversity
index for community 2 is going to be
equal to 1 minus i'll put a big
parenthesis here and we're going to have
925 over a thousand
squared
plus
40 over a thousand
squared plus 35
over
a thousand squared and if we simplify in
a similar way that's going to be equal
to one minus
all these thousand squares that's just a
million
and that's a common denominator and so
you're going to have 925
squared plus 40 squared plus 35 squared
and then this is going to be
approximately equal to
925 squared
plus 40 squared
plus 35 squared
is equal to this divided divided by a
million so divided by
one one two three one two three yep six
zeros is equal to that and then you
subtract that from one
and you get
which is approximately equal to zero
point one
and so we see very clearly when we use
simpson's diversity index that
consistent with our intuition community
2 has a lower diversity index than
community 1. and it's consistent with
our intuition that it is less diverse
and i encourage you after this video
think about why that makes mathematical
sense